we've gotten at least one call of duty  game every year for a while now so it  shouldn't be surprising to hear that  it's not going anywhere of course the  way we play call of duty games could  change over time Activision CEO Bobby  Kotick commented on this during an  interview with business site marketplace  org he stated we've had call of duty  games played on virtually every console  for the last 14 years so the idea of  having a game that centers around armed  conflict through history you never run  out of ideas for Call of Duty games  there will always be call of duty games  and they'll be played on a variety of  devices so rest assured FPS fans call of  duty isn't going anywhere the newest  entry in the franchise is infinite  warfare which launches on ps4 xbox one  and pc on november fourth you can head  over a game spot for plenty of coverage  on that and for all the biggest Call of  Duty news you're already in the right  place  you